hi I'm patty Kim we're going to take a
look around the laundry room and find
out how you can get your clothes clean
and be a green consumer all at the same
time now everybody knows that washing
machines use water but just how much
water may surprise you in fact next to
the toilet the washing machine is the
second biggest consumer of water in the
entire house now standard top loading
machines like this one right here take
about 40 gallons of water to wash a
single load of clothes that's nearly
twice as much as a high-efficiency front
loading machine front loaders tumble
clothes in and out of the suds using a
dryer like action this requires less
water which also means less hot water
believe it or not only about ten percent
of the electricity a washing machine
consumes goes to run the motor now the
lion's share of the energy a full ninety
percent is used just to heat up the hot
water alone so when you save hot water
in the laundry room you're actually
saving a significant amount of energy at
the same time high-efficiency machines
cost more to buy but because they're
cheaper to operate you'll save money in
the long run to get one of the most
efficient models look for the Energy
Star label when you shop for a washing
machine Energy Star doesn't rate dryers
but you can still find one that saves
electricity just look for a dryer with
moisture sensors these automatically
shut the Machine off when clothes are
dry so even if you're not using one of
those brand new high-efficiency washing
machines you can still save energy on
laundry day for starters logical thing
you can do is wait until you've got a
full load of laundry before you start
the machine then set the machine to wash
using warm or cold water and to rinse
using cold water so when the clothes are
done instead of using the dryer you
might want to just hang them on this
neat little contraption called a drying
rack will cost you a cent to dry your
clothes or if it's a sunny day you can
use this very high tech solar and wind
powered drying device called a
clothesline line drying your clothes and
using cooler water to wash can cut
29 percent off your energy bill you'll
also get clothes that smell fresh
without the artificial fragrances used
in fabric softeners now when you stock
up on laundry soap what you want to do
is read the label on the back and you're
looking for detergents that aren't
petroleum-based but plant-based avoid
soaps that contain phosphates which
deprived aquatic life of oxygen now
another ingredient to skip uh-huh
bleaches with chlorine because this
stuff is known to contaminate
groundwater what you might want to try
looking for is an alternative whitener
based on hydrogen peroxide or oxygen to
remove those nasty stains so by saving
water and energy in the laundry room and
by picking the right cleaning products
you'll not only end up with some clean
clothes but it also end up with a
cleaner environment that's it for now
we'll see you next time